digital blackface are going to wipe
people using black people in memes or
gifts to express comment relief or other
emotions is completely outrageous
disgusting Sexes and so on examples the
crying Michael Jordan the Tyra Banks how
dare you the Will Smith crying Meme and
so on right
um this is complete nonsense isn't it
why doesn't the same apply to white
people gifts and memes of which they are
a gazillion well first of all you
described it as being weird and secondly
your presentation in regards to
introducing this topic is as if you
don't care I don't and you should care
why and that's exactly why why is a
picture of Michael Jordan this article
was written because we need all to
understand what's happening here and
what's happening is is that there's this
Insidious toxic poisonous racism that
just underlies what's my sister about
Michael Jordan crying he's the greatest
athlete underlies this very issue and
why it's important for us why is it
poisonous to have a picture of Michael
Jordan crying as a meme